breaking news now the supreme court has
thrown a challenge to california's
restrictions on religious gatherings
back to the lower courts for
reconsideration now
remember the supreme court just ruled a
short time ago in favor of new york
saying they could not
prohibit different sizes of crowds at
churches well now what the supreme court
is saying is
they are throwing it back to a lower
court to have them reconsider
whether the state can dictate how big
church
crowds can be this is important because
it now mandates that the lower court
take a look at this again it keeps the
mandate by california in place but
again this will put it at the top of the
to-do list
on the lower courts to get this ruling
out
in short order uh we'll have more on
this as it comes in
to america's newsroom
meanwhile kentucky's attorney general in
a private christian school have filed an
emergency request with the supreme court
trying to overturn
the democratic governor's executive
order to shut
all schools down joining us now is roger
byron the attorney
for danville christian school thank you
for being here this morning sir
so the kentucky attorney general is
arguing that
private religious schools should be
allowed to be open
under the governor's current orders why
well the first amendment generally
requires a government to
treat religious gatherings of people
just as well as it treats
other gatherings and in the a code 19
context this means that
a government can almost never apply
restrictions to religious gatherings
that it doesn't also apply to other
gatherings and other gatherings include
things like
going to the movies shopping at a retail
center or a
shopping mall going to work in an office
going to work in a factory or attending
a wedding
and yet in kentucky almost everything is
allowed in person
but private religious k-12 schools have
been closed
i will read a bit from the lawsuit which
sounds a lot like what you just said in
kentucky one can catch a matinee
at the movie theater tour at distillery
work out at the gym
bet at a gambling parlor shop go to work
cheer on the wildcats or the cardinals
and attend a wedding
a parent can send his or her child to
daycare or preschool
and college students can attend classes
but all of kentucky's religious schools
are shuttered we know that there has
already been sir a response
from the u.s court of appeals it ruled
on sunday that the governor's orders to
close schools can
stand and here's a statement from the
governor while we all want to get our
kids back
to in-person instruction the united
states court of appeals for the 6th
circuit
recognized that doing so now would
endanger the health and lives of
kentucky children
educators and families do you further
challenge that notion based on the fact
that you've got dr anthony fouching
saying we've got to get the kids back in
schools there's
really no evidence that kids are
spreading this when they're in the
classroom
well certainly i mean in kentucky right
now under the governor's orders the
same group of people could attend a
friend's wedding and then head to the
gym together for a workout
afterwards they could catch a matinee at
the movie they could attend a concert
or as you said they could attend a uk
basketball game with thousands of other
people in rupp arena
afterwards they could swing by the
liquor store and if they wanted they
could go out and get
a tattoo and they could finish up their
night
at the indoor gambling slot machines
down at the horse tracks
what can they not do they cannot attend
a bible class at a private religious
school
that is not what the first amendment
requires
we know that justice brett kavanaugh who
will consider the filing
asked the governor to file a response by
friday has there been one yet
not to our knowledge but we're expecting
a response by tomorrow and he
kavanagh justice kavanaugh can act alone
or refer the case to the full supreme
court we will be watching this
closely sir appreciate you coming on
we'll follow up with you thank you